Hello, everybody. It is session number five on a new look for cancer
Talking about different suppressor systems as far as suppressor genes go
We said in order for cancer to occur there has to be a
Poptotic cycle that's broken in a replication cycle that is spanned up. Oh, that's usually has to do with also
blockied
What are called the tumor suppressor genes and the?
Uncle genes being turned on and we likened those to the tuber suppressor gene is like the brake pedal and
Uncle gene is like the gas pedal if you have the gas pedal stepped all the way out
But yet you still have a heavy brake pedal you may not hit them all and develop cancer
But as soon as you let up on that brake pedal if the gas pedal's on sooner or later we're going to hit the wall and we don't want that to happen
Well the tumor suppressor genes affect
Your ability to get cancer in multiple ways remember we talked about that
Cancer can be made like a receptor problem. It's a receptor of the cell membrane that is being affected
It could be somewhere inside the cytoplasm of the cell in the signaling pathways
Then are very complicated or it can be in the DNA itself
So different suppressor systems and suppressor genes work on all these areas to keep a person from getting cancer
All right, so what are the suppressor genes that we're going to talk about is suppressor gene P
53 because that's where most of the studies have been done is this specific suppressor gene
P 53 blocks the rapid replication. So if a cell doesn't go through apoptosis it starts the rapid replication process
If there's adequate
stimulation of P53
Then that doesn't take place in the person doesn't get cancer. So you may say how are we going to stimulate
P53 production in our bodies in our cells
with the cytoplasm so that it will prevent cancer in my
Life and will help further metastasis if I do have cancer because if I have cancer and if I can
So and I can express
P53 the chance of by getting metastasis goes down the chance of current
cancer that is replicated to stop replicating goes up so we want to express
Have a greater expression of the suppressor gene P 53
Well, first some of the things that could cause a suppression of P53. So a suppression of a cancer suppressor gene
will increase the likelihood of my
cancer or be having cancer
So things in our life that suppress P53 are listed here
Synthetic polyphenols particularly dies
Act directly on P53 and decrease production and decrease in block P53's ability to block
cancer growth pathways
Different chemicals in our food also do that same thing high calorie diets have also been found to block P53 production
So actually one of the couple studies out were quite interesting about
About fasting it just beat on a low lower calorie diet and the benefits of lower calorie diets are just amazing
But some of the things that we could do to stimulate P53
Are things that like eating a good diet cruciferous vegetables broccoli cabbage watercress
Bach Choi
Our fantastic for increasing P53 production
Vitamin C vitamin D selenium good nutrients are very helpful for increasing P53 production
This is where we talk about juicing
So
Juiced vegetables
Is so beneficial for us we know that so why is it beneficial one of the reasons it's beneficial is it increases P53
Production in our body
So let's chat a little bit about juicy because I know there's a multiple different theories about juicy that are out there
Most people have heard about the gurset program
So max gurset was a German medical doctor who came to the United States in the 20s and started
Helping people with cancer particularly a lot of different other diseases he worked with too, but he worked solely with their diet
he was
really a
grode
shaker in the
in the
whole dietary has to do with with disease process
paradigm
he was a colleague of the
of the person who started the doctor who started shackley the colleague of a person who started stated process
supplementation company and they were totally into the whole food idea of nutrition which is what we are into too
So his idea was simple that
God made food a certain way and we need to eat it that way and we don't always know why it does what it does to our bodies
but we take it in faith and
and go back to nature and how things were initially created
So his entire program is really based on that on that foundation of juicing
If you go to the gurset critic now currently run by Charlotte Gurson in Mexico
He she will find the exact same methods that that max taught when he died in early 1950s
uh those that's positive and negative there so we're going to chat about that
So the positive of the gursan program is that max was way ahead of his time
uh as far as teaching whole food nutrition
juicing was the staple of his whole program and uh he had some very philosophical
dogmatic ideas about juicing based upon the type of juicers that were available at the day
So you look at this picture and there's some different types of juicers
I believe on the far left is a champion juicer and then an omega juicer
I might have those two mixed up and then uh his door walk juicer is on the right
The door walk juicer is what is promoted at the gursan program
So if anybody here doesn't know about juicing uh these run in a rage from about $300 to about $2,500
The reason why backs produced uh actually had this produced and pushed the door walk juicer is
that it's a cold press juicer so first of all the food is the vegetables are grown up they're
put in a bag and they're cold pressed is that the best way of juicing the answer is yes
that cold press juice is the best way to get juice out of your juice you're going to get the most
out of the vegetables that you buy which can be economical uh but it has some downsides too
The reason why backs uh really toned cold press juicing is that the time the technology
that existed with juicing the centrifugeical juicers uh heated the vegetables and he
believed that if you're going to heat the vegetables you're going to destroy the enzymes in the
vegetables so that's all about the enzymes in the vegetables on what it does to your body
so uh that theory still stands in many camps uh raw food industry teaches the exact same thing
today as soon as you cook the food you destroy the enzymes and you destroy much of the benefit of
the food and that is very true the problem is that today's centrifugeical juicers do not heat the
food so to still hold on to that dogmatic idea that we have to use a cold pressed juicer or we're
not going to get the enzymes of the food is just unfounded so even the uh even the the cheapest
uh juicers like a jack-la-laden 99 dollar juicer does not heat the vegetables you still get the enzymes
out of the vegetables the negative thing about the the least expensive juicers is that you waste
a lot so you could feel the pulp from a norwalk juicer and it is dry as a bone you got all the juice
out of that pulp and you feel the the pulp from a jack-la-laden juicer and it's still pretty wet uh
it's just the nature of what's going on so to juice if a person is going to juice I typically suggest
you start with the least expensive juicer or uh something that's in your affordable range that you
don't uh spend such a high amount of money on because of the next thing I'm going to say so is juicy the
best way to get nutrients out of your food the answer is yes and no so here's the pros and cons of
juicing compared to blendine so on the far right you're going to see a picture of what's called a
neutral bullet in a nut promoting neutral bullet in any way you could use a Vitamix you could use
other things but uh the the the battle is between juiced and blendine so understand Gerson's program
so ex Gerson's program was uh was juiced it is currently juicing 13 glasses of juice per day so
basically on your waky day you're juicing a glass of juice every hour and you're drinking a glass
of juice every hour now there's pros and cons to that if you're going to do a program like that that's
going to be a high quantity of juice then you have to juice rather than blend so what's the difference
with juicing and blending well juicing is taking the fiber the pulp out of the vegetable and then you're
drinking solely the juice the benefit of that is you're getting mainly the nutrients you're losing the
fiber well I thought fiber was good for you well it is and it isn't so there's no way that you could
drink 13 glasses of blended vegetables every day you would too much fiber is going to completely
constipate you besides the fact I would challenge somebody to drink 13 glasses of blended
vegetables every day that would be almost impossible they would blow up so you have to juice if you're
going to do a high dose program like Gerson now at our clinic we typically recommend a modified
Gerson program so juicing if we're going to juice then we juice about 30 ounces of juice a day
so that's equivalent of maybe four glasses of juice a day five glasses of juice a day
if you're going to blend then we recommend blending you could blend three times a day
40 new to date if you want but at least one time a day the benefit of blending over juicing is that if
you're only going to drink one 12 ounce glass of the juice a day then you're better off blending you're
better off with that fiber so what fiber does in the juice is number one it can help your gut if
you're only drinking that much so it could help with constipation issues number two it will help
decrease the glucose load so many of my patients have diabetes as well and I know Charlotte juice
Gerson promotes hurts continues using her complete program with 12 to 13 glasses of juice even with
diabetes patients but if you're juicing a base of carrot apple celery which is typically touted
in the Gerson program in which I agree to that's very high in glucose so you are spiking a person's
glucose which can be an issue if you're going to blend you're getting the fiber as well so you're not
going to have such a glucose spike in that person's bloodstream so sum this up what's the benefit of
juicing the benefit of juicing in my book is solely if you're going to do high quantities of juice
you're going to do a juice every hour you need to juice the benefit of blending is that you're
getting the fiber and that could be good for your intestinal tract as well could help prevent
any constipation the fiber has benefits for you too you're not getting as high a concentration as
nutrients because you're not drinking as much of it the other side benefit of blending over juicing
is this it's just that you'll continue to do it I've seen over and over again patients go out with
the greatest attention I got a diagnosis of cancer I have to start juicing I buy a champion juicer
and I start doing it for about two weeks it's a lot of work it's a lot of work to get the vegetables
and juice them every hour or even if you did it three times a day or even if you did it
morning and evening the cleanup on it is can be overwhelming and a person can feel like they're
spending their whole life preparing their food and it could get very discouraging I've literally
had patients come in off the Gerson program a complete Gerson program and say if I have to continue
doing this I would rather die it's not worth it so we do not promote the full Gerson program if
somebody wants to we can instruct them with it we have full instruction about it but we typically
recommend a modified Gerson program so it really depends on the person's lifestyle so my philosophy is
that if it if it's so encompasses your life that you just basically are not excited about waking up
in the morning there's emotional ties to to doing something for your cancer that could override the
health benefits of that specific task so if if it's really easy to wake up and throw some
vegetables in your neutral bullet add a little water blend it up and drink it it tastes really good
and I could do that it reads out the cup and reads off the blade and put it in the sink and did I
I'm done versus getting it up getting the vegetables cutting up putting them in the juicer squeeze
it up down or have it a mulch down that I have to spend a half an hour cleaning the juicer every day
every time I juice so it just can be overwhelming and it over and over it's it's just patient compliance
after about three weeks into this I just don't do it anymore or I do it less and less and less
the the juicer is something that's sitting on your pantry shelf so what good is that the neutral
bullet just seems so much easier and it's all about patient compliance so the fiber is beneficial it
can decrease the sugar load of the juice and it can have benefits to your gut as well so I personally
use the neutral bullet you could use something else but you don't want to blend it for so long that
you actually heat it and you can't do that with a Vitamix you can't really do that with the neutral
bullet all right so I do have a complete discussion of juicing on a different program so look for
that as well next week we're going to talk about other suppressor systems and it will be good talk to you